it wasn't a flight to safety Sirens
continued to warn about airstrikes day
and night
but an escape from what Russia seems to
be planning in the occupied areas of
Ukraine
we were shocked we thought it was a
mistake but on the second day they
repeated the same everything was
happening so fast
the referendum and whether to become
part of Russia is taking place in
occupied areas in four regions in
Ukraine's east and south
median areas controlled by pro-russian
separatists showed pictures of people
casting ballots this is the city of
donets which separatists have controlled
since 2014.
but they don't control the entire region
and in areas under Ukrainian control the
mood was somber
here in potrovsk no one wanted to talk
to us explaining that people prefer to
keep their opinion to themselves not
knowing what will happen next
Ukraine and the International Community
have called the vote illegitimate
they want to keep the territory they
occupy but it won't stop our army we
will continue to liberate our land
Russia was waiting for this so it can
say that Ukraine is attacking Russia it
becomes a full-scale war and it can call
for full mobilization video has emerged
of armed men and electoral workers going
house to house asking people to cast
their ballots here in Cresson
people arriving in zaporija say it's
also happening in their areas
this elderly woman didn't want to show
her face because she still has relatives
in occupied berdians she tells me a
similar team entered her garden but she
refused to write anything on the paper
others also told us about how they sat
at home silently while soldiers knocked
at their door
but Polina was more worried about what
could happen next for two days I was
wondering I was crying but then we
decided to leave because of the threat
of mobilization of men my husband we had
no time we just left in a hurry
voting ends on Monday those we spoke to
say the results were decided before it
even started